what can you tell everybody about
the crazy jackass cast thread
honestly like when i received the text
from you guys in my mind i'm like
if only people knew the fl like what i
what i see what goes on the
conversations i feel so blessed to be a
part of of it it's pretty gnarly and the
access to early content drops i mean
i really i i'm so happy i get to be a
part of this chat and this you know this
family but yeah uh
it really is a special thread
except i think
poopy's kind of abusive he really does
and he should only like poopy should
only be able to promote like one piece
of content
i mean promote content also and you know
like there's other certain
pieces of content we receive from
poopies that no one should see no one
can not even
i don't think we should talk about it
it's nothing like illegal um it's just
criminally boring
it is uh i wish that there was a way to
revoke poopy's
um
access to this thread on center you know
like there should be like sensor like
there's you know how you can censor the
words you see on twitter and social
media
and the content you see it's not a bad
idea but i mean let's not create the
impression that uh that i'm mad at poopy
no we love cookies he's
he's he's very uh innocent in in
his own little way like
he's a special guy in the eyes of the
lord maybe but nothing
on anyone else's eyes right but but it's
a lot of fun and i bring it up because
you're so classic in that thread like oh
thank you whenever
it gets a certain point like there's 13
people in the thread so you've got every
single cast member old and new except we
man opted out i didn't even realize that
until uh dave england told me what he
meant
women's hasn't been in it for like i
thought he was anybody he just doesn't
respond oh no aaron barely responds yeah
and uh but everybody's in it tremaine's
in it you know knoxville like
um and and we'll get into this like
everyone's throwing in like zingers and
like it's a joke and it's almost a joke
off and virtually 100 of the time rachel
like chimes in with the funniest oh
thank you it's so fun to be a part of
it's fun it's fun i i definitely i will
say in the group chat poopy's butthole
has
made up made up an appearance yeah yeah
we all know it's not baby's butthole as
much as the balloon knot attached to it
right
what it's um
some would say it's art i don't know why
did he send that
say that
it's not that he didn't send it just uh
it made an appearance his butthole has
been revealed on set and it's become the
stuff of legends
and it gets referred to um
quite often
it's
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
best seller my first book's five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now by pre-ordering it at
stevo.com
yeah dude